you
[Music]
thanks for coming and thanks to zoom it
for for offering your your precious time
to visit us actually he is one of us so
he started in Microsoft research and of
course we were very proud of what he has
achieved so he he started in rise he's
the he's the main architect of Pendleton
and leads the which is a data wrangling
tool a data ingestion tool and he leads
the prose group that does that when I
read the abstract he was joking about
midlife crisis and it's shocking he's
way too young Rico and I we can joke
about about our midlife crisis but you
haven't earned the right yet you have to
you're way too young for that but anyway
we're really looking forward to to your
talk okay thanks Donald for them
introduction it's an awesome feeling to
be back in my home building here so my
research carrier has now spent 18 years
and in the second half of this career I
have led a different research lifestyle
than what I had in the first half and
this has given me much more personal
satisfaction and this is a story that I
want to share with you today and
unsurprisingly the story starts with my
midlife crisis so I saved enough to buy
my BMW I had won some ACM Awards I had a
decent amount of publications citation
counts index and it was climbing
steadily but then there wasn't but but
some form of you know deeper meaning was
was lacking the work that I was doing I
felt was not as much significant for the
society and the legacy that it would
possibly leave and this inspired me to
started looking for fixing this
situation and the idea was clear I
wanted to transition to different values
now by no means these value systems are
novel in fact they are very simple but
the reason why I am excited to talk
about them today is that they are
unreasonably effective in fact many of
you might actually already be following
these kinds of value systems how would I
have to admit that the academic word of
which we are all products off does not
emphasize these value systems as much as
it should the reason why I call them big
bets is because of that transition to
these value systems was not easy this
change is usually hard and I was very
intentional about making these making
this switch and this is something that
required a huge amount of effort which
makes up for an interesting story to be
shared however the most important thing
here is that these were just not my bits
I did not simply bet on this value
systems but I have also bet on the
people who are involved with this
transition this was the bet that even
those people made this was the bet that
was even made by the people who funded
these arrangements so this is a story
for of several of us together
so before I describe these four bets let
me actually provide some context in
terms of the research agenda that I was
working on and I would explain these
bets in that specific context so the
problem that had taken most of my
interest was soft program synthesis the
goal here is to automatically search for
a program in an underlying
domain-specific language from some
natural form of intent provided by the
user either in the form of input-output
examples or natural language and in fact
this had been an old problem almost as
old as programming but not much success
was achieved back then but in the past
decade we have seen some significant
advances in this area thanks to much
better algorithms and faster machines in
fact just to boast you know what we have
achieved now a few months ago we
conducted an experiment with some Python
programmers we gave them a data cleaning
task and they took on average 30 minutes
to finish this task we can do the same
task using our program synthesis the API
is in 30 seconds so program synthesis
can really improve the productivity of
developers by one to two orders of
magnitude in certain tasks two means but
what gets me even more excited is the
potential that it can enable non
programmers to create small scripts for
automating repetitive tasks 99% people
who have computers do not know
programming and these people struggle
with repetitive tasks in their lives
but these are not stupid people they
just don't know the artificial
programming language of speaking to a
computer but program synthesis
technologies can enable these people to
achieve much more in their lives now
because they can use computers much more
effectively so this is the context of
the research that I was in and when I
had this midlife crisis I was working on
program synthesis for trying to help
algorithm designers and
hardcore software developers and the
kinds of tasks that we were looking at
was to synthesize textbook algorithms
like sorting algorithms or the
synthesize tricky pieces of code that
even humans would take years or two to
come up with and this had to change so
the first bet that I placed was to be
able to connect to the customers more
directly because this kind of program
synthesis was not able to achieve the
kind of dream that I just outlined
earlier to be able to help developers in
their regular tasks or to be able to
help non-programmers with the tasks that
they struggle with so in this old word
the way I would choose the problem that
I would go solve would be mostly
inspired by what will help me publish a
paper in a top-tier conference what is
the next incremental or foundational
improvement that I can do which can get
me an X paper in a top-tier research
conference and the way I would define my
success matrix would be to either come
up with a benchmark myself in fact I
have written papers which just get cited
by the benchmarks that I chose there and
those benchmarks were just made up from
some imagination one afternoon and the
other way I would choose the benchmarks
would be to just follow what other
people would use in their in their
papers and this is the stuff that had to
change if I really wanted to connect
with real people and change their lives
so in this new word I found a lot of
inspiration from help forums by trying
to understand what were the pain points
of different users in fact more recently
we have been conducting exercises like
Moneyball where for six weeks we do
nothing but just try to connect to
customers who write scripts to figure
out contact information of customers
from different social networking sites
we email them to try to set up a phone
call if phone call looks promising we
invite them to a workshop at Microsoft
after running that workshop we figure
out what did not work well and we repeat
the process for the other three weeks in
when we do over delicious we're very
cognizant of putting in proper telemetry
and be able to get feedback from users
so this is a word that I wanted to be in
and the transition point came so there's
a small instant that I could share here
so I was coming back in an airplane
after presenting some program synthesis
innovations at the workshop and there
was a lady sitting next to me
and she was very impressed to know that
I worked for Microsoft and that I had a
PhD so she thought I better ought to be
able to help her with the excel tasks
that she was struggling with she opened
up her machine
and asked me how she can do one
transformation on her column and at that
time I had to excuse myself out of the
situation because I did not have any
knowledge about the programming model
inside Excel but that gave me hint that
these are the kinds of simple tasks that
I need to or I should consider going
after as opposed to trying to come up
with three key big vector algorithms or
reinvent sorting algorithms which have
been known for ages because that
research is not going to help anyone so
I spent months trying to a steady
spreadsheet help forums to figure out
what problem should I be solving which
simplest problem can yield the biggest
benefit and what should be the initial
target benchmarks that I should be
working with this was a typical
interaction that I noticed on a help
forum an end user would ask an expert on
the help forum can you please give me a
script or a program that can convert the
string on the left side of this arrow to
this string on the right side of this
arrow the expert would look at this
input output example and will provide a
script that would say extract two
characters starting at the fifth
character now the end user will take
this program and figure out that it
doesn't do the right job at this other
input the expert looks at it again and
probably tries to have a better model of
the intent that the user has so what do
you think is the end user trying to do
here
tokenizer next
yes so extract everything that is
between the first two underscores and do
you know how do you program how would
you program this in Excel so Excel as a
programming model and this is not the
simplest programs that you can write so
even if you know programming you'll have
to go to Stack Overflow or some kind of
documentation to figure out what is the
API that Excel exposes but you are the
lucky one the one person people who know
programming think about 99 percent
people who do not know programming they
will be stuck well in this case the end
user takes this script and runs it and
sensor thank you to the expert and this
is a feature that we designed which
shipped in excel in 2013 and was quite
received quite a good reception so it
also let me publishing this particular
paper so this is one of the hundred plus
papers that I have published in my
career
most of those papers have the similar
kind of intellectual depth but this is a
work that I am most known for so why do
you think this is the case this is
because this not only this work appeared
in our top to your conference but this
work also solves a problem that real
people care about that shipped in Excel
and this is something that I would say
does not happen that often it is very
easy to do one of the to write software
that is used by millions of people
everyone in office does that or write a
research paper and all the searchers do
that but the intersection is one which
is really really makes this paper
special now several people often comment
that Osama got lucky because he worked
at Microsoft so he figured out the
problem from there and the Excel team
you know gave him the benchmarks the
truth is even the Excel team was
inspired from us looking at help forums
to figure out what a target benchmark
should be they didn't really give us the
much benchmark going to really help us
much in terms of terms of benchmarks and
the way I went about identifying the
problem definition and figuring out the
benchmark is something that any Academy
could have possibly done themselves as
well they didn't need to be inside
Microsoft to do that the course
really is what they'd be willing to
spend three months doing nothing just
looking at health forums and that is
what this change was all about that is
the disk the bed that I took in my
career which I think you know paid off
quite well it really is a funny story
beyond how he got this taper accepted so
few days before I was about to submit
this paper to this conference I started
going through the email where I had
accepted the invitation to be on the PC
for this conference to just see how is
strict their standards would be for PC
submissions and then I realized it said
single authored submissions from PC
members not allowed and then I sent a
mail to that she are saying I believe
this is the most important paper in my
life that I have written above until now
and I happen to have agreed to this
weird requirement that you have do you
want me to include my wife's name on the
paper and then within a few hours an
email gets sent out to all the UC
members saying this I want to lift this
requirement unless you know someone has
an objection and that paved the way for
me to submit this paper and this really
changed how I started conducting
research after this point onwards after
we got addicted to this kind of success
we wanted to now apply this kind of
programming for examples to many new
different domains so instead of just
doing string transformations which we
applied it to do number transformations
for instance even a task as simple as
rounding a number to two decimal places
requires you to remember different kinds
of format descriptors in different
languages but again examples are a very
natural way to specify intent here or
maybe think of a task which is a bit
more involved and you'll have to spend
several minutes trying to think of a
script to do this conversion but again
these are the kinds of tasks that now we
can do with a few examples we applied it
to the domain of extracting tabular data
from log files this is an assignment
taken from a data science class where
the instructor asks the students to
extract the tabular data that you see on
the right side and the instructor gives
them a script to start with so the goal
is to take this script and
build on it to go from left to right but
the experience were designed all that
the user has to do is to give an example
of two or two of the various fields that
they want to extract and then will
automatically be able to extract other
instances of that field we applied it to
manipulating semi-structured
spreadsheets it turns out 50% Excel
spreadsheets are semi structured in the
task of going from the left to the right
is usually quite involved but again this
can be facilitated by simply a few
examples so this application domain that
I mentioned to you is can be clubbed
under what is called data
transformations or data wrangling and
this is where data scientists apparently
spend 80% of their time before they can
bring data into a form where they can
apply machine learning to in order to be
able to build interesting models another
killer application is code
transformations if you want to help
users or developers migrate their quote
from one platform to another one from an
old version of a framework to a new
version of their framework in such
migration scenarios they are apparently
spending 40 percent of their time doing
repetitive code edits but again this is
a scenario where they can give one or
two examples of the edits they want and
the system can automatically suggest
them all other places where they might
want to do such transformations so huge
range of applications basically this is
the thing that I wanted to really
emphasize here but how did all of this
actually come about even starting with
the fact that I told you that you know
this powerful paper that I wrote on
flash fill I spent three months just
stating the hell forums and only three
weeks coming up with an algorithm and
implementing it and maybe a couple of
other weeks writing writing the draft of
the paper but then it took two years to
ship this product with Excel and it was
no mean feat the first support that I
got was from my manager at the time
Ben's on who played the perfect selfless
role of ensuring that this technology
actually meets its right fit it was very
hard for me to win connect to the right
set of people in Excel in order to be
able to show them this technology
but Ben had the right sort of context
and he facilitated that we had an RHD
who devoted himself for one or two years
in order to be able to do this tech
transfer with Excel we had a PM Shabnam
balakrishnan who played the right role
in dealing with the upper management as
well as the people on the ground in
order to get this technology shipped out
I think the star of the show has to be
the chef Singh who came here for three
different internships and when his OPD
finally the então ran out we shipped him
to India so that he can work for us from
there he took this technology to a
completely new level
there were many interns who followed who
worked on these different variations
that I talked about like extracting data
from log files extracting tabular data
from semi-structured spreadsheets
Gustavo who worked on doing code
transformations from examples Mark who
is in the room here who led work on
programming by natural language there is
one important character missing on this
slide who do you guess what the role of
that character would be
so I'm talking about you know my
partners here right so she was a course
three internships two internships a
contactor position two-year postdoc
almost like you know another one year of
funding where does this funding come
from so this is the funding God you know
who enabled this arrangement so Rico was
running this impossible things
initiative at that time and he took bet
on this technology so that it can
actually see where it ought to be so now
we invested into so many different kinds
of task domains for program synthesis
but there was one big challenge that
developing each of these program
synthesizers was a very tedious effort
it required you to think of an algorithm
from the beginning it required you to do
an implementation and if you want to do
a robust implementation you have to
spend months engineering it and also
people in academia started rumors that
oh so myth is now only doing practical
research so it was not time for payback
and all the environment was well set up
for the second bit which was to develop
a framework that can facilitate the
design and development of these kinds of
program synthesizers for various
individual domains so in the old world
we would invent a program synthesis
algorithm for scratch for a new domain
and we had worked on 20 such domains and
each of them would be publishable in a
top tier conference and we can keep
continue to crank there but we wanted to
do something better so we wanted to
develop a framework that would be
parameterize by various domain specific
concepts so that it can guide our
algorithmic thinking it can make the
time to engineer robust
synthesizer from once to a few weeks and
furthermore this will also pave way for
doing new research but now the new
research that will be done will actually
provide value for all different domains
as opposed to being domain-specific so
this is how the framework actually looks
like so in the old world you would have
a synthesizer for each domain which will
take as input examples in real output a
program and this is what the model
inside flash fill is but the first kind
of parameterization that we did here was
that instead of having the search
algorithm be very domain-specific and
having a separate search algorithm for
each different domain we parameterize
this search algorithm with the
underlying domain-specific language in
which we wanted to synthesize programs
so now to develop a synthesizer for a
different domain you can plug in a
separate domain-specific language
another interesting point here is that
examples are a very ambiguous form of
users intent then you give me one or two
examples the number of programs in my
domain-specific language that match
those examples is often 10 to the power
50 so we need to pick a program that we
believe matches the user's intent and if
we don't get this right Excel will not
ship flash well in fact they demanded
that for most simple tasks we ought to
read the mind of the user from just one
input-output example because otherwise
people would loose trust in this
technology they would not use it it will
come up with funny interpretations and
the ranking algorithm that we used was
intertwined with the search algorithm
but this was a good opportunity to
separate the two things together so now
the search algorithm returns a program
set the set of all programs that match
the examples and now we have a separate
ranker which can take the program set
and produce a ranked program set and
furthermore this ranker can be
parametrized by different kinds of
ranking functions or features we can
also build interactivity in this loop we
can actually guide the user in deciding
if they need to provide us more examples
or not and once we believe that they
might have a correct program we can show
them the program in our domain-specific
language which can then be translated to
any language of
choice like bitin our C sharp or Java so
this is what the overall structure
architecture looks like but how did you
get here you're exposing it to the user
in the domain-specific language right
and you are the other motivation you
have is the user who doesn't know yes
good question right so that end-user
only interacts with the red color here
the blue color is done by researchers or
advanced developers like us so whoa Lee
had developed this system called flash
extract which would extract tabular data
from log files and we wanted to also
extend this work to be able to extract
data from web pages extract data from
semi structured documents and then he
ended up doing another implementation of
flash extract for log files so that it
becomes general enough that we can also
extract use the same framework to
extract data from web pages from
spreadsheets and this resulted in some
kind of generalization and the step
towards this framework we're another
intern Dilip keeney who worked on
extending flash fill to doing much more
complicated tasks so experimented with
new interaction models he experimented
with new synthesis techniques and I
would say it was a mild success it
resulted in a paper but not did not make
as much dent as we had hoped for but
these were kind of fine steps you know
two fine steps towards the process
around the same time I had an intern
Alex polos of is actually in the room
who was being randomized by me on many
different kinds of projects and he was
watching this thing happening from the
sidelines and then he came to me and he
said you know so much I can solve the
problem that you're really looking to
solve here but he was not clear whether
he would want to solve it or not how
would this actually work out because he
was a student at
u-dub and solving this problem really
required you know big dedication I
convinced him several weeks and then
finally he decided that he will actually
be doing his PhD at Microsoft Research
you know working full-time on this
particular project and so he did he
actually solved this problem and I think
this is a beautiful paper and that that
he authored but while he was focused on
developing the nuts and bolts of the
framework we required vou to
reemployment flesh extract yet and at
that time
so first implemented flash extract for
log files actually that was a second
implementation of flash extract for log
files because it was one other person
harm inventor who had developed the
first implementation but unfortunately
he left the company after a year then
would develop flash extract the second
time who implemented flash extract the
third time so that we can generalize it
not just to log files but to other
formats and then he provided great
service to Alex by reimplemented stacked
in the most general framework that we
now have so four times implementation of
flash extract and not only that other
interns who are also around or who could
participate try to implement what
they're done in the framework that LX LX
proposed so just imagine the amount of
investment that is going into this
implementing flash extract the fourth
time
what business value is that adding and
who on earth would fund that effort you
I give you a lot of you know probably
too much credit last time and I when I
said that that that you funded flash
fill in flash extract because any sane
person you know would want to throw
money at that is so cool just looks so
cool from this concept but who would put
money on this this is the real credit
they're actually forgets again months of
internship paying for the stipend of LX
for the entire year paying institution
you know is quite expensive but this is
the place where Rico really put his foot
forward
not sure if he trusted he would put a
bet on the project but probably you also
put a bet on me so it was it was his bet
on both the technology as well as people
now what was the next problem here so I
have to tell you folks you know alex is
a talent he is one of the best engineers
that I have known and he could deal with
the sophisticated theory that is there
inside this vapor it's hard to find gems
like him
absolutely Harden right I cannot you
know just manufacture new Alex's in and
put them together and also he needs to
be left alone to decide his own you know
paths and directions in life so how can
I carry forward this mission where I
really need to take this framework and
make it production quality if we just
continue to depend upon interns this is
not going to work out because interns
are going to leave they can come for
three internships they can again extend
their contact for another six months
they can we can continue to get angel
funding from Rico but this model is not
going to not go into sustain so
something you know has to really change
and this brings me to the third bet
which is about my belief of putting
research and engineering engineering
together so if you recall the success of
flash fill relied on two years of
engagement with the Excel team where we
had build a research prototype and the
Excel team took it and copied it line by
line into C++ so our c-sharp code was
copied line by line into C++ and if they
had any issues performance issues or
some bugs that they needed to fix they
would get back to us we would fix it in
our code and then they would take take
it but we want to do more such things
and you want to accelerate eight them
right
so using this model of what we call tech
transfer is not going to work here we
have to build and deliver that tech
ourselves also the option to open source
and forget
that way before they put the software
that you were building so that's an
interesting question in my field said
that time is still not right before we
get there because we are still in the
early stages I think the project needs
to be matured up to a certain level when
open sourcing it will start start adding
value also my role up until now was more
of an individual contributor of course I
was working with many collaborators I
was involved with 20 projects in a year
and in one year I was working with a
total of 50 people on those 20 projects
so I was not alone but I was still what
I will call an individual contributor I
was splitting my time into multiple
projects spending 5% of my time on this
project 10% of my time on this project
and these were all you know disparate
projects or maybe loosely loosely
connected but what we needed was a team
which can which will have a shared
mission and which will actually work
together so I sometimes joke and explain
my situation you know this past
situation of individual contributor as I
was having multiple girlfriends at the
same time which was of course a very
thrilling situation but now with a team
it is like being settled in a family
where everyone has the same mission and
working towards the same thing then
another thing that got me quite inspired
from one of Peter Lee's slides on
different quadrants is the appreciation
of two different styles of research one
of which he called long-term blue sky
research and the other thing was
short-term mission focused and I used to
think that I need at some point of time
I need to be in one of those quadrants
but this is the assumption that I
started challenging and now what I
believe is that we ought to fund blue
sky research by using mission focus
deliverables and we need to find
synergies between these two these two
goals so how would this research and
engineering be put together so here is a
slide that I
which tries to capture some of my
thoughts here so first I noticed that
there is a quite a parallelism between
the research word and the engineering
word and both those words have
appreciation for long term processes as
well as short term value proposition
that they could that they offer so what
like slash will would actually fit in
this bucket where our goal is to work on
the next shiny thing write a research
paper make a quick impact they work on
flash meta this is the framework that
Alex built will fall in this bucket here
and normally what we would do is we will
do multiple instantiations first like
flash fill flash extract flash normalize
special eight and we'll then try to
generalize them into a framework this is
the old word this is the old typical
academic word but now for a change what
if we productize the framework and then
we start building innovation on top of
that framework and this is a new word
which will speed up innovation also by
trying to do something cool and then
trying to figure out what kind of
consumers or customers can have impact
or in which product can I put my
technology there's a very fine way of
doing things but I think in the new word
what I would like to do things is
completely the other way around where I
would first like to connect with
customers and try to understand what are
some of the relevant problems so that I
don't waste my time trying to solve
problems which are not as relevant and
what problems are equally intellectually
interesting right but if I have a choice
I would rather pick something that is
more element and furthermore if I set up
my engineering processes right then all
of these three quadrants are going to
actually have a push on to innovation so
even if I end up spending a fraction of
my time in this quadrant the fact that
I've invested here in these other
quadrants is actually going to push and
accelerate the development of new ideas
and their delivery so this is what we
also see you know with the interns that
we sometimes get so I'm a tech
speedin swear if I get a very smart
student but who is not that great at
engineering they actually sometimes
struggle because with the limited time
that they have there they are able to
try out only few ideas but someone who
is probably not as good but a much
strong engineer is sometimes more
successful because they're able to try
out many more ideas in the same amount
of amount of time so this is the kind of
a structure that I wanted where
engineers and researchers would be
working synergistically and this is the
team that I now have where the goal of
researchers is not to develop prototypes
and throw it to engineers for them to
productize know researchers have to do
product quality implementation of their
ideas but I do acknowledge the fact that
not everyone is like Alex people are not
trained to be great software engineers
but as long as the engineers on the team
are willing to give the researchers
guidance on how to do write software
engineering and as long as the
researchers are open to picking up on it
it will work out and this is the
arrangement that I have on my team right
now
and furthermore it's teamwork
so while every researcher on that team
has the ownership of some important
capability all these capabilities are
coming together towards the common
mission it's not like everyone is trying
to create their own islands of
excellence so as a research manager my
responsibility is to make sure that
every researcher in the team shines with
whatever they do but it also all
coherently fits together as as part of
one single big mission so many people
think that I'm running a product team or
an engineering team this is completely
not true I'm running as strong a
research team as you might find inside
this building the only reason why I
moved out was because I did not want to
be a burden on MSR or more of a drain on
MSR I wanted to leave the angel
investors like Rico free to fund new
enterpreneurs like summit
this is the kind of model which I
believe is more sustainable this is the
message that I want to spread around
that product groups should fund research
not just as a as a philanthropic
activity but it can really increase
their business it can really bring them
distinguished value to their business
and if we start thinking like this
there's a huge amount of money in this
word now outside of this small little
organization that we live in and it is
inside this outside word that which
should be seeking real funding that goes
beyond angel investing so this is a
message that I really want to want to
share here so now last the final bit and
this is about my belief in
cross-disciplinary research the initial
bug actually hit me when I was working
with NEBOSH who was part of the reason
why I even joined Microsoft Research
admin in the first place because we saw
potential of applying machine learning
for program synthesis per sorry in the
bush I didn't follow up too much on that
in after our initial project but more
recently this has come to be very true
so cross-disciplinary research is hard
for many reasons it is difficult to
explain to the other community that you
have done something meaningful it is
difficult to receive funding in that
thing you're not really an expert expert
in that area so what do you typically do
I
you might just ignore it you can ignore
it for various reasons one is an you
might ignore it
is that you really believe that you know
your community has the right tools and
techniques to take a stab at that
problem or you might ignore it because
you simply you know don't don't care
it's like a stretch hiding its hand head
inside the sand or the other option that
you have is to remain in
all of the other kind of technology and
the change that are now imbibing in my
new word is that belief that the third
wave of AI will actually combine the
techniques from my area which is that of
formal methods logical reasoning
techniques and from that of the machine
learning community all the statistical
learning that is that is there but how
would I go about doing this
cross-disciplinary research I am NOT an
expert in this area I really need to
find the right empathetic expert who is
willing to be a partner because simple
collaborations for the sake of writing a
paper are not going to help and push
this thing much further so let me
actually explain to you what are the
opportunities for why I believe that
combining logic and machine learning is
quite important for creating many
different kinds of AI software so here
is some intelligent piece of some
software that that behaves intelligently
and three instances of such pieces would
be the three components that I showed
you in this framework for program
synthesis one was the search algorithm
the ranking algorithm in a
disambiguation algorithm so such an
intelligent component is often composed
of two different pieces logical
strategies or algorithms that we
understand very well and something that
I would like to call creative heuristics
if I further drill down into the
creative heuristics at least in our code
base we find that it is made up of
various kinds of features and some
weights over those features for instance
is a constant point eight being used in
my code base so as a researcher I do use
point eight the answer is it just seems
to work well but in the new word it
would be fantastic if developers or
researchers focus their time on
identifying the right features and
writing what is a well understood
knowledge
and leave the model building exercise to
a machine-learning bagged runtime this
can help us come up with not only better
models and make us more effective but it
can also lead to these systems being
adaptive and personalized so just
imagine you know when flash fill is
running on different users machines if a
user is dealing with the same kind of
data one over again then instead of
having to give two or three examples the
system can understand their intent from
just one example in some cases even
point one examples of zero examples it
and I can formalize that maybe if you're
interested you can talk to me after the
talk so this kind of adaptivity would be
possible only if we are using some
automated way to fine-tune the creative
heuristics or the ranking strategies
that are inside underneath the software
so this kind of division would
facilitate that so I can go a little bit
more into into this detail for each
other three components that I showed you
in the program synthesis framework so if
you recall there was a search algorithm
that was parameterize by a
domain-specific language and the
domain-specific language is usually
specified as some rules in a grammar and
we have a fancy search strategy that we
use to explore that grammar in order to
figure out the program that satisfies
the user's intent there lots of
heuristics that we use actually in order
to make this process scalable and robust
which grammar production to try first or
to not try
which disjunctive with sub goal from a
disjunction of sub goals to explore when
we are trying to make our progress
towards the goal and each of these
decisions can actually be learnt from
large amounts of data that we have and
if we use the right machine learning
modeling and learning there here is
another example of program ranking so we
have many programs that match the users
input output examples but we need to
choose one of those programs so need to
have techniques that can rank different
programs and this ranking is based upon
syntactic features of the program or
even features of the outputs produced by
two or three different
programs on a given set of inputs now
what weights do you use for these
different features and this is again
something that can be learnt from
machine learning in fact some features
are more machine learning than than
logical light like is this string the
name of a person and in the
disambiguation box that I showed you we
need to communicate some actionable
information to the user so that the user
can decide if they need to provide more
examples or are they done we can show
users some corner cases where they need
to provide more examples but there are
many heuristics that are used inside
this process that can be machine learned
for instance when to stop asking
questions so every question comes up
with some kind of probability or
threshold and if it is above that
threshold we present it to the user but
what is that threshold or if we want to
cluster the inputs based upon their
syntactic structure this is again where
machine learning techniques can be quite
useful so in order for us to make big
advances in this area My partner in
crime has been fatigued Jen who is a
world-renowned machine learning expert
at MSR I and he received great support
from other colleagues at the lab and
then he also brought in a lot of
resourcing in the form of interns and
research fellows and this is what it
takes to start experimenting with such
cross-disciplinary research in a serious
way and again all of this arrangement
was facilitated by Shyam Rajamani who is
the lab director who wanted to bet on
this this direction of research so I'll
conclude now so I talked to you about
these four big bets that have brought in
a lot of value but there are also new
challenges that have come in and I'll
just summarize those here so when we
talk about connecting with customers and
gathering real data or maybe in the form
of telemetry or figuring out where my AI
solution is not
kingvale so that I can improve the
improve my AI offering we are going to
have new challenges with respect to
collecting data because of the GDP our
requirements so an interesting research
problem that this opens up is how can
you get data back without violating any
of the privacy issues that can yield you
enough information that you can innovate
on your service and we already actually
have a lot of real customer data and we
want to release it in service of the
Academy community and for other
computers should try out you know your
ideas but the problem is the damn
problem is the data is so real that we
just cannot release it it is the
opposite problem now so we're not trying
to see if we can fake up this data so
that the real challenges of synthesis I
still preserved but the data is
completely picked up and then we can
release this it the other thing that I
talked about was taking a framework
based approach to designing and
development and one challenge that of
course always remains is how to balance
between specialization and
generalization because with a fixed
amount of funding you know resources
time either you can structure something
that is very intelligent for a vertical
domain or you can do something that is
less intelligent for a more in a
general-purpose layer so you always have
to you know make the right set of
choices there it's not easy
the third bet I talked about was putting
this such an engineering together and
here it even involves doing an
end-to-end delivery of your offering
what about maintenance now you put this
thing out and then are you committing to
maintaining it indefinitely and even
people management is an interesting
unspoken aspect here when you are
running a big team of people working
together and then the final thing that I
talked about was the significance of
cross-disciplinary research and one
challenge that comes here is how do you
balance between doing some quick
experiments versus doing things in a way
so that you are already always
production ready